the dust had barely settled on the Epic
Spider-Man no way home when producers
Kevin feige and Amy Pascal jointly
addressed the future of Tom Hollands
Peter Parker Holland was joined on
screen by former Spider-Man Toby Maguire
and Andrew Garfield in his third solo
outing as Marvel's wall crawler which
smashed pandemic era box office records
and received widespread critical Acclaim
speaking to the New York Times just days
after the release of Spider-Man no way
home Pascal and feige got candid about
the future of the franchise Amy and I
and Disney and Sony are talking about
yes we're actively beginning to develop
where the story Heads next next which I
only say outright because I don't want
fans to go through any separation trauma
like what happened after far from home
that will not be occurring this time
Pascal added that the ending of
Spider-Man no way home gives him a lot
of narrative possibilities for the next
film two weeks before no way home even
came out Pascal told Fandango we are
getting ready to make the next
Spider-Man movie with Tom Holland and
Marvel we're thinking of this as three
films and now we're going to go on to
the next three this is not the last of
our MCU movies